mon entreprise c'est la metiss création
édition je te cite le jeu à métis est un
jeu de culture générale et patrimoine de
l'île de la réunion comme ami mais le
maloya dessiner la cascade biberon les
cartes piège faudra les chanter j'étais
barré ça je m'étais occupé beaucoup de
mon père était malade très très malade
et il est décédé
et de là je me disais j'ai du temps
devant moi qu'est ce que je vais bien
pouvoir faire
j'ai touché un petit peu à tous les
corps de métier mais je m'épanouisse
c'est pas je voulais créer quelque chose
de moi même je voulais quelque chose
d'innovant j'ai toujours aimé jouer même
comme les enfants étaient petits je
jouais avec a énormément de jeux de
société on a besoin de rire
et puis un soir le déclic faut faire un
jeu sur la vie
donc il fallait le lâcher prise sur la
joute pour laisser au fond prendre la
place et de la l'aventuré commencé j'ai
suivi son parcours pour l'initiation de
l'idée jusqu'au que la concrétisation du
projet avant de se lancer elle était
plutôt géré pape et si elle avait
beaucoup d'hésitations vu que forcément
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
gros donc beaucoup de motivation courage
je suis très fier de son parcours
sachant que son jeu également fait
partie du programme périscolaire
aussi la création du jeu joie que les
impôts aujourd'hui intellect les plus
partageant des parents et les enfants et
moi j'ai voulu créer un jeu
intergénérationnel en eau des couples
avignon en revêtement de la réunion et
ça s'adresse à un large public
pour le moment on peut le trouver le jeu
à l'aéroport de pierrefonds à l'afr les
trois musées de l'île
et puis avec moi même
et ce constat le shanxi créateur va
aider la métisse à avoir plus de
visibilité
il faut aussi que tous les réunionnais
qui sont expatriés puisse connaître jeu
l'entreprise a pour but d'améliorer le
jeu la metiss niveau 1
la metiss juniors où les enfants verront
bientôt le jour
ensuite il y aura un jeu d'apéro un jeu
de rôle il y aura le jeu sur le
développement durable des éditeurs pour
le jeu c'est un terreau métropole dont
je me suis dit je vais aller moto
indiqué moi-même et demain peut-être que
les 85 qui vont créer des jeux et ben je
pourrai vous accompagner
je pourrais être là pour eux